[Music]
mommy how was Nebraska it was
um the
usual Mr bracket can you tell us what
happened at night at the hotel it was
our anniversary so we wanted to go out I
won't be me you won't be you just two
strangers meeting in a
bar tomorrow
night
I'm Jack Alice do you and your wife
roleplay often what exactly is this
about do you know this man no Jack Bob
Bob Jack pleasure he just talked for 5
minutes to all the victims of her charms
and then he
left the one and only hey where are you
I'll be right
back the wife's real name is an aell
wanted for contract killings across
several
continents
[Laughter]
I'm
sorry
what they told me what you are my wife
is an
assassin this is a lot you kill people
it's over I never want to Del Li to you
I just want a normal life that I have a
family to protect you're my wife I am
coming to help you do not come here you
hear me do not come
here
I love you and I love our family we can
get through this we are concerned about
your wife and the safety of your
family she kills me this one I told you
I need out I'll bring the whole world
down on your
[Music]
heads I love you I have to go to work
now though
okay never met a girl like me before
killing is bad like unacceptably bad I
know I know I'm done done I
[Music]
swear